[Music]
hi I'm Sally today I'm going to show you
how to make a lastly potted plant cells
you will need a wooden board made of
spruce for small flower pots which sorry
bought at a DIY store for plants of your
choice sorry has opted for cactuses a
power drill a hole saw and a drill bit
self-adhesive contact paper and tape for
creating the pattern brown cream wax a
paintbrush and a container for the paint
various paints sorry chose for different
colors a roll of plastic sheeting sarees
using food bags plus 2 brackets for
small screws and four large screws with
wall plugs to fit first arrange the
flower pots measure them exactly and
mark the position with a pen drill holes
using the whole song or get a carpenter
to do it now coat the wooden board on
all sides with the cream wax next paint
the flowerpots and leave them to dry in
the meantime you can draw your desired
design onto the self-adhesive paper and
cut it out stick your design onto the
outside of the flowerpots this allows
you to give them your own individual
touch then paint the pots again in a
different color once dry remove the
contact paper
lying the base of each flowerpot with
the plastic sheeting so that no water
can seep through you can now put plants
into your pots finally screw the
brackets onto the board ready for the
shelf to go on to the wall you can also
make it as flowerpots of different sizes
if you like that better